My goal at the end
of this talk is
you walk away
learning something,
whether it's just
about an R package
or you have some new strategies
in terms of approaching some
of your more technical solutions
with end users or clients
or what have you.
So a quick introduction.
My name is Tanya Cashorali.
I got my first
start with R in 2005.
I was working at Children's
Hospital informatics program,
analyzing genetic data, and
I've been using it ever since.
I love R. I started my own
company based out of Boston
called TCB Analytics in 2015.
And I always have
to include Porkchop.
He's my assistant.
You may see him come
in here at some point.
But do feel free to contact me
through any of these avenues.
More than happy to
answer questions
if we don't have
enough time either.
So what is anomaly detection?
This is just the
Wikipedia definition.
It's sometimes referred
to as outlier detection,
but I like to say it gets
a little fancier than just
detecting standard deviations
above or below a mean.
It's a way to identify
rare items or events.
I typically use it
for time-series data.
Twitter actually developed the
package, which I'll get into
and they use it to look
at tweets per second.
You can use it for CPU
metrics and utilization,
but I'll talk about
two different industry
cases in which we
were able to use
and had a lot of
success doing so.
So the R package, like I said,
was developed first at Twitter,
and there's some
really good papers
that I link at the end of this.
The slides are available.
I definitely recommend it.
There's some good
reading in there.
I won't have time to get into
all the technical details,
but I actually used a
fork from hrbrmstr
and he made a few modifications
to the package, one of which
is it returns tidy
data frames, tibbles,
and he also made the function
names a little easier snake
case aliases so you can see them ad ts
for time series and ad vec for vector.
So this is the package.
It's been phenomenal
for us so far.
Now just to talk about
the implementation
or the underlying
algorithm, very briefly,
it builds upon an Extreme Studentized
Deviate test, just a big word
for saying it does some
time series decomposition
and robust statistics.
And the paper I mentioned
actually benchmarks
these four approaches, linear,
a seasonal decomposition
with loss, and a quant spline.
The one they said
actually performed
the best was piecewise median.
So it looked like
stable metrics typically
exhibited very little change
in the median over two-week
windows.
So it defaults to breaking
your data into two week windows
and calculating a moving median.
It also accounts for intraday
and weekly seasonalities.
It was pretty much performing
on par with these more
expensive calculations.
It's four times faster
than the other ones.
So that's the red line
you're seeing here.
We've had no performance
issues and have given it
quite a bit of data and we run
it everything in real time.
So I love that
this track is also
called working with people
because it's the hardest
thing we do. R code
and math is typically easy
compared to working with people
and that's what
we do day to day.
Typically, the problems
when implementing
complex technical
solutions comes down
to communication breakdown.
It always comes down to that
between developers and end
users typically.
So oftentimes we'll get a
set of initial requirements.
And when building data
products, they almost always
change or get thrown
out the window.
There's just so much
that any end user,
I don't care how much you
know the product or the data,
there's so many things you'll
never be able to predict
and that could happen as soon
as you start building. Or an app
gets into production and
it just doesn't meet the
end users' expectations.
They may have given you
a mockup or a wireframe,
but there were a whole
bunch of other edge cases
that they just didn't think of
that they want to then tackle.
And we see that happen a lot.
And this happens because
not all users have
the technical understanding.
Sometimes they have a
limited understanding
of the statistical
processes and principles,
and then developers may just
take those user requirements
and run with them and
they disappear and come
back with an end product.
And lastly, developers are not
always including those users.
So you don't want to disappear,
and then just come back
to the user with something
that they may have
not actually wanted.
So part of that art is figuring
out exactly what the user does
want compared to what
they're telling you.
And that's where
Shiny comes into play.
So we've had a lot of success
just taking ideas, connecting
to real data and showing
the users something
tangible, something that
they can interact with.
And what we found is using
Shiny as a collaboration aid,
we see those requirements
quickly change.
We see the user get
excited because they're now
touching something real and
working with something real,
and they feel more engaged.
They feel a sense of
ownership that typically they
wouldn't have if you were
just a developer off doing
your own thing and disappearing
for weeks or months
and then coming back
with something that they
didn't necessarily feel
like they were a part of.
So this is what I like to
call rapid prototyping,
and it enables you to
demonstrate value before doing
this full scale implementation.
It enables you to find all
these different edge cases.
And data scientists can focus
on problem solving instead
of having to play this
back and forth of, well,
what exactly do you want?
You can solve a problem quickly.
Come back, show the
client something,
and then keep
iterating that way.
So to get into the examples,
the first one I think
is pretty cool.
It's a
hardware manufacturer
in life sciences.
They essentially build the
rapid blood testing machines
that in hospitals.
So if you go to the hospital,
hopefully not when you're there and you
get your blood taken.
This is the company
creating the devices that
give you those rapid results.
They have sensors in them that
relay quantitative metrics
and help diagnose
instrument failures.
But what this
company was doing was
deploying the
hardware in the field
and finding out retroactively
that there was a problem.
So they would take
the machine back
and analyze all of the data
coming off the machines.
This seemed like a
perfect opportunity
to use anomaly detection.
We wanted to identify those
problems before they went out
into the field.
So here's what the data and
experimentation looks like.
We have various metrics
coming off these machines.
There are things like
protein levels and analytes,
and they come off at different
aggregations 24 hours,
12 hours, et cetera.
This anomaly detection function
has a bunch of parameters.
And we just played
around with some of them
and iterated on things like
what percentage of the data
should we capture anomalies for?
Should it be positive
and negative direction?
So above or below the
expected threshold.
The level of significance.
Maybe we really need
to be stringent here.
Maybe we can only go with
90% confidence versus 99%
And then that piecewise median
period that I mentioned.
Another thing we realized is
there are some outliers that
are just insane and anomaly
detection would  always pick up,
and that's very indicative
of a hardware failure.
But the client already
knew about these.
They said, well, we know
that these are problematic.
So we actually did
some outlier removal
and then ran the
anomaly detection.
And of course then there
were no anomalies detected.
The input data very much makes a
difference on your end results.
So those are all parameters
we wanted to play with.
And we were literally
manually analyzing all of this
and it turns out putting
it into a Shiny app
and just allowing
myself and the client
to play with these
different parameters.
We quickly got feedback
on, hey, this actually
looks a good threshold to use.
These are good parameters.
Let's run with these.
From there we
thought, well, instead
of a sort of top down
approach and exploring
all the different options,
let's alert the user
and exactly where to go.
So we took the high significance
anomalies, highlighted them
and allowed the user
to then click one.
So I want to more
about this one.
What's going on with
potassium or calcium?
And it would bring you right
back to that screen
pre-populate all the
parameters, again just
a nice little user experience
thing, time saver and they
could dig into the
details a little more.
The code was pretty
straightforward.
The input data looks just like
you'd expect for a time series.
There's a time
stamp and a measure.
We iterated over the
different significance values.
We also defaulted to
using one year of data
prior to the date
range of the client
is actually interested in.
So if I care about May
of 2020, let's start
with data from May 1st of 2019
to get some of that seasonality
and more data is better
for this type of algorithm.
But throughout the project
they then informed us, hey,
we actually have these
limits that we already know.
It's like you consider
it a prior in Bayesian  math.
And so.
Upper limit,
lower limit is something
that they would say
these are automatically bad.
So we thought, well,
this seems like it's
guiding us a little more and we
could probably integrate this.
First, we start with a
completely data driven
approach, agnostic from
any business logic.
But then we said, well, maybe
we can incorporate these limits.
And even giving them a
simple tool like this
to explore those
different outliers
was something that
they didn't have.
And they were really doing
this all pretty manually
and by hand.
So then we combine those rules
with the anomaly detection.
And this is over a
course of a few months,
we got better and better
refining these parameters.
So now the colors you
see here, the green
is just an anomaly
that the algorithm
found based on the parameters
we already tweaked.
The blue means it's approaching
that threshold limit.
And these lines,
these vertical lines
are those thresholds
which vary by analyte.
And then the red is both.
So we decided these
are probably most
important to look at because
there's strong signal here.
Not only are you approaching
limit, but it's the anomaly
detection is saying this
is trending differently
based on this piecewise median.
The other thing we
did was allow the user
to specify how
stringent they wanted
this approaching limit to be.
So here you can see it's
not that close to the line.
We were able to
define thresholds.
Like maybe they really want
it to get close and the way
we did that was
based on quartiles.
So the closer they
were to the quartile
of that range, the top quartile
that was more stringent
and so on.
And we let them kind
of open up the lens,
so to speak, to be
looser, more stringent.
This ended up being the best
approach for the client,
just not only was
it the algorithm,
but incorporating the
business logic as well.
So I want to jump quickly
into the next example
so that we have
time for questions.
The other example, and
I should wrap up also
that they're using this
on a day to day basis.
It runs as a Shiny app.
They're able to connect
live too their database.
And it's been used as a
tool to basically direct
their investigation and
identify these hardware
failures before the machines
get shipped out to the hospital.
So we thought we think that's
a really cool application.
And it's R and Shiny.
The price tag is pretty good.
So real-world example
again is another client
that works in the sports
and entertainment business.
They actually do market research
around sports technology.
So things like in-venue
betting and understanding
how to engage fans in
this new technical age.
Biometric sensors on
athletes, you name it,
basically any sports
technology and I
like to call them kind
of a market research
company for sports tech.
So what they have is a
whole bunch of news articles
that they collect
via Feedly, diffbot,
but these are different
third-party tools.
And Leo is something that's,
I believe, part of Feedly
and it analyzes all the
information for you.
It's kind of like a smart filter
to bring in the information
take care of.
So the data is thousands
of sports news articles.
There's also entity tagging
that this Leo tool does
it tags sports teams
technologies vendors
meaning vendors like
Google, Microsoft, Nike.
Technologies being
anything from blockchain
to augmented reality.
And so what we
thought here was they
wanted interesting news
stories to be surfaced to them.
So we simply took the
number of mentions
of these various
entities over time.
So you can imagine Boston Red
Sox are mentioned 10 times
a week.
Suddenly they're mentioned 30.
Let's investigate why.
Here's what the first
iteration looked like.
We have a date range.
We have.
They can filter by
league if they'd like.
We're looking at
all leagues here
and we have a list of anomalies
that the R package bubbled up
to the top.
The Seattle Sounders
here were detected.
We click that and it
gives us a time series.
Look at that particular anomaly.
We can then click
it and discover
more about what's happening.
So on that date
in Shiny pops up,
this nice little module, the
Seattle Sounders and Amazon
worked together.
Amazon had acquired streaming
rights for Prime Video soccer
matches, and that's a huge
thing that this company would
like to know about.
So from there you can see
how you can rapid prototype
and it might be manual in
your surface some anomalies
but you could imagine how
this could be automated
and to report, give me the
five most interesting stories
that week.
Give me the teams that are
spiking in the news and so on.
Another cool use case
for them was we used it.
It doubled as a QC tool,
so some certain things
would be spiking
that shouldn't be.
For example, the
Ottawa Senators,
they weren't doing
particularly well.
There was really
no reason it wasn't
like the playoffs or anything.
This is an NHL team, so
we decided to dig into it.
And it turned out
that diffbot was
tagging OTT for the
Ottawa Senators
because that's our abbreviation.
But it also stands for
Over the Top Streaming
Services.
So we had identified a
problem with the tagging.
We alerted diffbot,
and we got that all
fixed on the data itself.
So it can also be
used as a data QC tool,
not only to surface interesting
things, but potentially
problematic things, as we talked
about also in the first example
of finding hardware failures.
And I'm leaving, I think, at
least 4 minutes for questions.
But final thoughts again,
working with people is the hardest
thing. We're lucky
that usually they're
people we've worked with so
far understand the problem
and they're very collaborative.
And I think being able to show
them these results piecemeal
is what builds up the confidence
and their understanding
of the tool and why it matters.
Giving them the why or allowing
them to dig in to the why
and explore more in their own
is that sort of self service
and freedom of analysis that
they need to really feel
like they're engaged.
So Shiny has been just
incredible for that
because I remember the
days where you just
had to show them static charts
and put together a PowerPoint.
And it's very much like
I'm just talking to you
rather than working together.
So anomaly detection is
a useful data driven tool
when used appropriately.
In our cases, we had
identified specific needs
for each scenario and
tailored them accordingly.
The first use case
was for proactively
identifying hardware failures.
We learned over time that
incorporating their threshold
limits would actually give
us more accurate results
rather than just relying on
the data. And the other use case
surface
interesting news stories as well
as doubled as a data QC tool.
Work always work closely
with your end users
via that iterative process.
Shiny again is
fantastic for this.
I always say build
fast and fail quickly.
I'd rather show you something
that you think is terrible
and you tear it apart.
And getting that constructive
criticism to me is a good sign.
It means you're invested.
It means you have ideas.
And it means that we can
improve upon it very fast.
And then don't leave out
important business logic
where it can help you.
We don't always have to just
rely on statistical models
and assume it's going to
solve all our problems.
There's often times that we
can incorporate that domain
knowledge and it can
really improve our results.
So always be looking for
those pieces of logic that
can help your automation or
your math or your R package.
And questions.
Feel free again to
contact me here.
I look forward to hopefully
being there next year
and enjoy the rest
of the conference.